tommy
tommy listen to me he is the contractor
he's the contractor okay i can't lose
this job
i i understand
let let's talk about this in the morning
okay
we'll talk about it in the morning
all right good night
hey
scoot
sunday at work huh
what are you still doing up it's late oh
crud what time is it it's way past your
bedtime still today
honey please not right now i do not have
the energy for this
here
what's this
your birthday
you kept complaining about broken watch
so i figured you know
you like it
honey this is
it's nice but i
i think it's stuck it's not what no no
no
oh ha ha
where did you get the money for this
drugs
i sell hardcore drugs oh good we started
helping out with the mortgage then
yeah you wish
[Music]
and that baby girl
[Music]
uh
hello sarah honey i need to get your
daddy on the phone uncle tommy what time
is it i need to talk to your dad now
uncle tommy
hello
what was that all about
dad
daddy
[Music]
we've received reports that victims
afflicted with the infection shows signs
of increased aggression
there seems to be some commotion coming
from
[Music]
dad
dad
what is going on
there's his phone
eight missed calls where the hell are
you
call me on my way
oh
[Music]
there you are sarah
are you okay
yeah
does anyone come in here
no who would come in here don't go near
the doors just just stand back there
dad you're kind of freaking me out
what's going on it's the cooper's
some may ride with them i
think they're sick
i'm kind of sick
jimmy dad come here come here
you shot him sarah i saw him this
morning
there was something bad going on
you've got to get out of here do you
understand me
yeah
tell me come on
where the hell you been
you have any idea what's going on out
there i got some notion holy [ __ ]
you got blood all over you ain't mine
let's just get out of here they're
saying half the people in sydney lost
their minds can we just please go i'm
sort of parasite or something
you gonna tell me what happened
later
hey sarah
how you holding up honey
i'm fine
can we hear us on the radio
yeah sure thing
thanks
no cell phone
no radio
yeah we're doing great
a minute ago newsman wouldn't shut up
they say where to go
they said uh
army's put up roadblocks on the highway
no getting into travis county we need to
get the hell out
take seven seven i
swear they say how many are dead
probably a lot
they found this one family all mangled
inside there
right
i'm sorry
just christ how did this happen they got
no clue
but we ain't the only town
first they're saying it's just the south
now they're going on about the east
coast the west coast
holy hell
that's lewis's farm
i hope that some [ __ ] made it out
i'm sure he did
are we sick
no of course not how do you know they
said it's just uh people in the city
we're good didn't jimmy work in the city
that's right he did
we're fine trust me
all right
let's see what they need
what do you think you're doing keep
driving i got a kid joe so do we we have
room
keep driving tommy stop
you ain't seen what i've seen
someone else will come along
you should
oh this is bad
everyone and their mother had the same
damn idea
we could just backtracking
tommy holy [ __ ]
the [ __ ] just happened what the [ __ ]
just happened did you see that yes i'm
sorry god damn turn here turn here
no no no no no come on people move what
are they running from
get us out of here i'll try it
oh no
we can't stop here i can't [ __ ] drive
through them go back up there they're
behind me too there they're there hold
on go
daddy
hey
hey
get back
get back
oh
dad
i'm here baby
give me your hand
what is it
my lick hurts how bad pretty bad we're
gonna need to run
god
keep us safe
hold on tight
daddy i'm scared
just keep your eyes closed
keep looking at me baby
[Applause]
i promise
get back there's too many of them
this way through the alley
go
he's dead
god damn it
we're almost there we're almost there
baby
they're getting through the fence
keep going find a way out of here
come on
go
move it
get to the highway
go you got sarah i cannot run him uncle
tommy i'm gonna
[Music]
they're getting closer
dad
it's okay baby we're safe we're safe
hey
we need help stop please it's my dog i
think her leg is broken stop right there
okay
we're not
sick
got a couple of civilians in the outer
perimeter please advise daddy what about
uncle tommy we're gonna get you to
safety and go back for him okay
sir there's a little girl
but
yes sir
somebody we've just been through hell
okay we just
ah
oh no
sarah
move your hands big
i know baby i know
listen to me i know this
you're gonna be okay baby stay with me
i know baby
come on baby please
no baby
[Music]
sarah
[Music]
baby
don't do this
don't do this to me
no
no
no no no no
please
please
[Music]
the number of confirmed deaths has
passed 200. the governor has called a
state of emergency hundreds and hundreds
of bodies lining the streets
panic spread worldwide after a leaked
report from the world health
organization showed that the latest
vaccination tests have failed
with the bureaucrats out of power we can
finally take the necessary steps los
angeles is now the latest city to be
placed under martial law all residents
are required to report to their
designated courts riots have continued
for a third consecutive day and winter
rations are at an all-time low
a group calling themselves the fireflies
have claimed responsibility for both
attacks their public charter calls for
the return of all branches of government
demonstrations broke out following the
execution of six more alleged fireflies
you can still rise with us
remember when you're lost in the
darkness look for the light
believe in the fireflies
hmm
i'm coming
how was your morning
want one no i don't
want one
well i have some interesting news for
you where were you tess
west end district
hey we had a drop to make we
we had a drop to make yeah well you
wanted to be left alone remember
so i'll take one guess the uh
whole deal went south and the client
made off with our pills is that about
right
deal went off without a hitch
enough ration cards to last us a couple
of months easy
you want to explain this
i was on my way back here and i got
jumped by these two [ __ ] all right
and yeah they got a few good hits in but
look i managed
give me that
are these [ __ ] still with us
well that's funny
at least find out who they were yeah
look they were a couple of nobodies they
don't matter what matters
is that robert [ __ ] sent them
our robert he knows that we're after him
he figures he's gonna get us first son
of a [ __ ] he's smart no
he's not smart enough
i know where he's hiding
like hill you do
old warehouse in area five
can't say for how long though
well i'm ready now yeah oh i can do now
[Music]
[Music]
the checkpoint's still open
only on a few hours left until curfew
well we better hurry up then
i gotta serve the damn papers this
morning
i've been selected for outside work duty
soldiers are supposed to handle
i'll
the
outside
look at that
rationline hasn't opened yet
it must be running low
kidding
again
leave me alone
seems like more people are getting
infected
that just means more people are sneaking
out
i got us all new papers they shouldn't
give us any static up there
just play cool
you see who i need there you go
what's your business here got the day
off visiting a friend
all right move on through thanks
out of here
[Music]
immediately
[Music]
so much for the easy route
patch yourself up all right
they're gonna close all the checkpoints
we're gonna have to go around the
outside
outside the wall
or we could just let robert go
cute
hey tess you see that [ __ ] i was there
hey how's the east tunnel looking yeah
it's clear i just used it no patrols and
where are you off to gonna pay robert a
visit
you too who else is looking for him uh
marlene she's been asking around trying
to find him marlene
what do the fireflies need with robert
you think she'd tell me well what did
you tell her the truth i got no idea
where he's hiding good man
hey you stay out of trouble all right
military's gonna be out in four soon
yeah see you around
marlene looking for robert what do you
make of that i don't like it
we better find him before the fireflies
do
this is us
hey guys how's it going
shit's stirring up out there how are we
looking over here uh it's been quiet
no signs of military are infected that's
what i like to hear
joel give me a hand with this
yeah i'll take it easy out there